apparently
playing snow white wasn't all that easy
if you've watched once upon a time
you know that although it takes place in
a world of magic and fairy tale
characters
the series is actually pretty serious or
is it between fighting off ice monsters
true love kisses and breaking curses the
once upon a time cast is
actually hilarious when they aren't
acting who knew how funny getting bitten
by mosquitoes could be
or that the cast occasionally broke out
into a dance number between takes
not us if you're in the same boat as us
or are just prepping for a once upon a
time binge watch on disney plus
get ready to check out just how much fun
this cast had
filming the series for seven whole
seasons
actress lana perilla was an icon both on
and off screen
she was literally the best evil queen
also known as regina mills we could have
asked for
and so nice to fans but being beautiful
and evil for us on camera
apparently wasn't as easy as it looked
especially when the set props
weren't cooperating is it supposed to be
i think the set workers took making her
look wind blown to a whole other level
but i mean we're glad it took some trial
and error if it meant giving us
epic scenes like this one as once upon a
time fans
we definitely spent a lot of time
watching fave characters like elsa
emma and snow white discovering the
wooded enchanted forest
but there was only one character that
actually turned into wood
you guessed it pinocchio let's just say
it was
painful turning into a wooden doll both
on and off screen for actor eon bailey
there's no denying that emma swann was
unique in basically every way
i mean she's the savior for crying out
loud but besides her magical true love
powers and keen sense for sniffing out
lies
there was actually something common
about her her name
i bet the majority of you watching
definitely know an emma and because of
her name being common
it brought some major trouble for archie
a.k.a raphael sabarge
when it came to filming this season one
scene emma stone
did i say stone
there was no way once upon a time was
getting away with not
including the classic snow white scene
of biting into the poisoned apple that
puts her into a sleeping curse
but we're betting it was a whole lot
easier to make the animation look
graceful than it actually was in real
life
have you ever tried to bite into an
apple gracefully during filming of this
scene they had to record
multiple takes just take a look at why
let's see like get a little more
gracefully grab me our apple please
the cast of the series have mentioned
how beautiful it is filming in hollywood
north
vancouver multiple times but the
canadian forests come with a little more
than just
natural beauty mosquitoes there's
nothing like a good old bug bite to
completely ruin the mood
any guesses on how many times the cast
hit one another over the years trying to
get rid of pesky bugs we're
guessing at least a hundred
like we mentioned before once upon a
time might be a serious show
but the actors certainly aren't in fact
they spent a lot of time breaking their
scenes by bursting into laughter
we'll make a bet that you can't get
through these next few clips without
cracking a smile along with these very
professional actors i ended up with a
dwarf tavern
i'm sorry did we win who knew trying to
say dwarf tavern could be so hilarious
we all fell head first in love with the
epic true love ships that once upon a
time gave us
snow and charming emma and hook rumple
and belle
but there may have been a romance going
on behind the scenes that we had no idea
about
you know rumple and hook as enemies but
could they have been something more
any ship name ideas rook humble
maybe we should start a poll when we saw
injuries happen throughout the seasons
we all knew it was movie magic making
those injuries seem real
but what about the injuries that
happened behind the scenes and without
movie magic sorry he crunched me right
in the nose
sometimes it wasn't laughter that made
the director's call cut
in fact it might not have been given to
us on camera
but colin o'donoghue actually broke his
foot while filming this scene in the
musical episode
what a trooper like we saw with lana's
wind machine situation
the cast didn't always have the best
luck with props in fact
mishaps happened pretty often on set and
a lot of the time
it was hilarious runaway cars spilled
drinks
malfunctioning shackles just another day
on the once upon a time
set next up we have a dance break
interlude
brought to you by the cast of once upon
a time it's clear from all the bts
moments that the cast had a blast
filming these seven seasons
so much fun in fact that they felt the
need to randomly break out into dance
sessions
i mean did you ever think you would see
elsa raise the roof
neither did we i think it's safe to say
that not only were the once upon a time
cast a plus
actors but they weren't hard to look at
either if you know what i mean
apparently charming's actor josh dallas
was also very aware of this
just look at this blooper from season 4.
i didn't know you're enjoying us
you're enjoying it jennifer morrison
just
couldn't contain her laughter for this
one forget about the ice wall
hook was coming to enjoy them
ever heard of the phrase stare into the
camera like you're on the office
well apparently colin o'donoghue has
because he did it
pretty often whether it was to give us
his classic smolder
break character in the middle of a scene
or to show off just how goofy he really
is
it gave us some pretty epic behind the
scenes material
michael scott who
you know that moment when you make a
mistake and you can't help but make a
funny face
well the once upon a time cast can 100
relate of course it took a lot of work
to get to the level of perfection we see
on our screens when we watch the series
but just take a look at some of these
hilarious
and weird faces and noises these actors
made when they messed up
honestly these bloopers might be better
than the actual scene itself
actors are on set for long hours every
day and sometimes through the night as
well
so can we really blame them when they
forget what they're supposed to be doing
for instance josh dallas thought he'd
magically popped onto the set of a
shampoo commercial in this blooper
and then in the same scene thought that
his character charming had a thing for
captain hook
just look at colin blush do you know
those moments where
everything just becomes funny and you
can't stop laughing
well the actors in this series were
definitely not immune to those moments
especially jennifer goodwin she just
couldn't contain her laughter
after her on and off screen husband josh
dallas made her giggle
it looks like this might have been a
long day for everyone on set
sometimes things just don't go your way
and the same applies to each and every
actor in this series
could you imagine having to memorize all
the scripts that they do
we're pretty sure we'd mess up just as
much as they did but
it probably wouldn't be as funny it
doesn't even sound like they're speaking
english in some of these bloopers i have
to admit
i don't remember my line there's nothing
like filming a show that takes place in
a mythical world and then getting
interrupted by modern technology
sorry that was me
or more accurately transportation chugga
chugga choo choo
well at least selena's actor rebecca
matter took the train interruption in
stride
in fact she may have enjoyed it a little
too much
we all went through that grade school
phase of making harmless jokes about one
another's mamas
your mama your mama and apparently so
did lana perilla
she loved that phrase so much she took
it to a whole other level while filming
once upon a time
there was a yo mama for everyone on set
that day
when season seven came around our fans
got a lot of new faces on our screens
each week but it seems like not much
really changed behind the scenes
especially when it came to the wind
machine just like lana had problems on
season one alice's actress rose reynolds
did too
what makes it hilarious is that the air
actually scared her during each take
she wasn't ready they say having kids is
a joy but what about working with them
well if these kids are anything like
lucy's actress alison fernandez we're
betting they are
she had everyone on the set of season
seven giggling
even the evil queen herself all these
bloopers have shown us that once upon a
time actors are the exact
opposite of the show's serious tone i
guess that means fans got the best of
both worlds when it comes to enjoying
the show
and it's behind the scenes moments let
us know what your favorite blooper was
in the comments section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button for
more magical videos just
like this one